hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
ja letztens im video welche bei meinen
porsche geredet habe schon erwähnt
scheint mir die kommentare ob ihre böse
kommentare lesen vorlesen video nochmal
wollen ich lese heute mal wieder
komische böse kommentare vor
ich habe nämlich letztes dieses bild
hier bei instagram hochgeladen wo ich am
hockenheimring bei sei die ganze sache
wo ich mit porsche eingeladen wurde beim
rennen wirklich mal alles so zu sehen
ringsrum bamm bamm
ich hab natürlich gedeckt auf dem foto
und dann kam unter dem bild kommentare
wie hey gutes bild luca bin großer fan
von dir ich liebe dich so sehr und unter
anderem auch ich hasse dich ich bin
extra wegen je nach köln gefahren
das kann mich auf jeden fall
nachvollziehen ich deswegen zu hassen
ich meine du fährst extra wegen mir nach
diesem fest überhaupt noch köln was soll
ich ihn ko ich bin extra wegen die nach
köln gefahren
du sparst jetzt bis zum hockenheimring
habe ich gegen die gesagt hat sich in
köln bin ich dort nicht die chance die
zuseher dafür extra wegen
und du willst einfach nicht als ich in
new york war habe ich dieses bild hier
aus dem central park hochgeladen das ist
dieser fahrradweg wo man herfahren kann
und die sonne gingen ok die sonne ging
gerade auf der anderen seite runter aber
das bild fertig trotzdem sehr cool ging
der skyline im hintergrund und so weiter
und so fort darunter kamen an der
kommentar von c punkt schiller und zwar
ist das in england schrägstrich usa
das steht sogar der ort angegeben der
untertitel von dem bild war in der ruhe
liegt die kraft weil alle machen ja mal
so tolle instagram titel wo die anime so
tolle sprüche hinschreiben venture und
die fleisch und der ganze scheiß
darunter dann natürlich meine fans
wieder in der tomate liegt der saft also
der spruch ein bisschen umgeformt in
bezug auf tomatensaft und dann kommen
von witzige pigs noch der kommentar in
der ruhe liegt die scheiße ich finde es
immer toll auf einem niveau
die kommentare
leder ist kein niveau dann war ich in
berlin am potsdamer platz war im sony
center weil ich ja in dem angry birds im
vogel gesprochen habe
da habe ich halt dieses bild hochgeladen
ich fand's cool wie ich das stehe und da
sind diese komischen paparazzis die
fotos von mir haben wollen ich weiß
nicht wieso man mich freiwillig
fotografieren will darunter hat mir
wieder meine community gezeigt wie samt
nett und freundlich man untereinander um
geschenken maxi hat nämlich geschrieben
du stinkst nach fisch und darauf meine
community halt jetzt einmal was dein
problem jedoch einfach deswegen liebe
ich dieses bild wird bei den
synchronisations arbeiten im
synchronstudio zum engel über strip das
ist übrigens nicht gesponsert für den
angry birds film oder song also nicht
dass jemand jetzt denkt weiß dass darauf
der vene
also ich bekomme er folgert mix ist
einfach nur ich habe alle kommentare von
instagram genommen weil da die meisten
beschallten kommentare ankommen ich bin
derzeit am aktivsten auch instagram also
fahrbereit sein war mit laser luca
darunter haben sich zwei zuschauerinnen
um mich gestritten und zwar lebe ich
jetzt mal eine unterhaltung vor mini
schreibt mein schatz darauf antwortet
fremd sie neben meiner dann wieder mit
hinein er wird mir dann fragen sie nein
er gehört mir das ist mein baby baby
baby drama vergessen da kommentiert medi
natürlich wieder hoffentlich er gehört
mir und dann hat franz die tolle idee
wird verteilen ihn ein fucking käding
okay aber ich krieg mehr rover und nie
gleich viel
ich habe mir nie auf den stuhl des bis
wieso hilft das auf dem boden in meine
freunde also es ist jetzt nicht so dass
ich irgendwie sowas habe ich ja schon
voraus gesagt ich bin jetzt kein pokal
oder so den mann rum reicht unser herr
jetzt hast du ihn jetzt und jetzt mache
ich noch ein foto mit ihm und jetzt ich
bin mensch mehr zeit hätte es nicht
wusstet hier ist dein statement
dann hätte ich finde das immer ultra
krass irgendwie so ich scroll wieder
durch instagram das schreiben so viele
leute einfach irgendwie so erzählen und
ich liebe dich und kennt mich doch
eigentlich gar nicht richtig oder als
ich es keine ahnung jetzt machen die
leute die so etwas schreiben die so
schreibt ihr sowas also warum wie das
ist ich bin ich bin
ja ich kenne euch nicht ihr kennt mich
nicht also ihr kennt mich ja nur über
die wir machen weiter ebenfalls als ich
in new york war habe ich dieses bild vom
rockefeller center hochgeladen
da gibt es ja immer relativ viele
plattformen sich doch es gibt drei oder
vier verschiedene höhen wo man sich
hinstellen kann dass sie bei der
höchsten höhe und darunter zeit noch
eine plattform also selbst wenn ich da
runter gefallen wäre beim machen des
bildes wäre ich nur auf die plattform
geklatscht hätten wir wahrscheinlich
einfach nur mal den es irgendwie
eingeklemmt oder irgendwie so war der
oper carmen halt echt viele kommentare
dass ich nicht springen soll allerdings
keinen kommentar wirklich weiter mein
leben vorbei wäre sondern nur so etwas
in die richtung wie hinein luca sonst
kannst du keine pizza essen oder luca
nicht springen sonst kannst du keine
pizza essen einer noch geschriebenes
sollen backflip machen ich finde auf
jeden fall immer cool was dafür
priorität der meiner community gesetzt
werden also dass man nicht sagt luca
passau wo sonst bist du tot und kann es
nicht mehr leben sondern hält du kannst
keine pizza essen was natürlich auch
irgendwie wichtiger ist als das leben
tausenden kommentaren darunter dass ich
nicht springen soll meint auch eine
person namens cool affen land.de
selbstmord du opfer niemand verhieß dich
nicht als sich dann noch verleast werden
ich meine du hast dich bald tatsächlich
sieben wörtern fünf mal verschrieben
das ist da vielleicht habe ich
irgendwann lokal wenn partikeln den
später ich habe keine pokal gefunden
aber ich habe in welche kopf bin ich
also denen würde ich jetzt einmal als
ich beim völkerball wenn doch prosieben
war habe ich dieses bild hochgeladen wie
ich einfach im stadion sitzen quasi auf
das spielfeld schaue dabei ist eine
kanne zusatzinfo bevor wir den kommentar
vorlesen auf diesem platz geht
normalerweise tennis gespielt bei den
gerry weber open und in dem moment oder
dort völkerball gespielt für die tv-show
kubica darunter geschrieben ich wusste
nicht dass du gerne fussball schaust
fußball
wir haben verdammt nochmal völkerball
gespielt hat er ja auch nicht und einer
kugel wieder geschrieben was bei sieben
euro
was weißt du schon
nun auch wieder zu einem sehr sehr
kompetenten kommentar unter diesem bild
und zwar kommt dieser kommentar von xx
flow 1998 xx er schreibt nämlich
schicken
ja danke für deinen kommentar letztens
habe ich auch dieses bild hier hoch
geladen wo ich mir ein laserschwert was
ich irgendwie zugesendet bekommen habe
einfach zwischen die beine gesteckt habe
und mir eine star wars maske aufgesetzt
hat man davon foto gemacht habe darunter
kommentiert wieder die schinken wachsen
die ja vorhin schon kommentiert hast du
stinkst nach bestimmt werde kacke hey
schenken mag sie wendet es vielleicht
wie nachher stickig denn mich gibt's
dann vielleicht das letzte bild was ich
heute zeige ist dieses hier das habe ich
immer länder holten l gemacht als ich
jan in l war darunter hat der nutzer mit
dem namen misses conny darunter
geschrieben mein penis ist steif
warum tut ihr etwas an
an dieser stelle wenn ich jetzt auch das
video meine damen und herren ich habe
mir mal wieder unter den letzten bilder
anhalt kommentare rausgesucht und wollt
ihr euch einfach mal präsentieren was
dort vereine hat dummheit vorhanden ist
vielleicht als solcher gefallen wer das
getan hat und ihr habt bock auf mehr
kommentare luca macht auch mal nette
kommentare keine ahnung was zeigt mir
mit einer bewertung schaffen wir auch
kein plan 50.000 leicht ich weiß wie
viel ich kann ich sagt so was ja immer
so sagt einmal das video